FATHER. ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS
BAY PACKER FOR JUST BRADFORD
CABALLERO QUARTET THREE DALLY
DODD THE RAZA EGGMAN GLAZER
GONZALEZ GROWTH HERTZBERG WEST
SO- TADO JONES KAMLAGER LAYERED
LEYVA LIMÓN MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MEN
NEWMAN NIELSEN A SHOW OF BOTH
PAN PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO
SKINNER. KERN AMBERG WHITE HOUSE
SKI WIENER WILK. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE.
MEMBERS BEFORE WE MAYBE WE BEGAN
I ASK EVERYONE TO OBSERVE A
MOMENT OF SILENCE FOR THE
VICTIMS OF THE MASS SHOOTING.
THAT OCCURRED EARLY SUNDAY
MORNING IN SACRAMENTO. THE FIRE
HEADS.
THANK YOU. WE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON BY SENATOR
KAMLAGER AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING WE WILL BE LED
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG BY SENATOR DR SO. ON
THIS ANNIVERSARY OF THE
ASSASSINATION OF REVEREND DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR WE
PRAY HIS PRAYER. OH GOD WE THANK
YOU FOR THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE
INSPIRED MEN AND WOMEN AND ALL
NATIONS AND IN ALL CULTURES. WE
CALL YOU DIFFERENT NAME SOME
CALL YOU ARE LARA SOME CALL YOU
ALLOW HIM SOME CALL YOU YEAH
HOVA SOME CALL YOU BRAHMA SOME
CALL YOU THE UNMOVED MOVER. BUT
WE KNOW THAT THESE ARE ALL NAMES
FOR ONE AND THE SAME GOD GRANT
THAT WE WILL FOCUS THE GRANT
THAT WE WILL FOLLOW YOU AND
BECOME SO COMMITTED TO YOUR WAY
THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
ESTABLISH IN OUR LIVES AND IN
THIS WORLD A KINGDOM OF
UNDERSTANDING. WHERE MEN AND
WOMEN WILL LIVE TOGETHER AS
BROTHERS AND SISTERS AND RESPECT
THE DIGNITY AND WORTH OF EVERY
HUMAN BEING WE ASK THIS IN YOUR
NAME. ON IT. COLLEAGUES JOIN ME
I PLEDGE. BY UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. YEAH. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. ARTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR THE WEEK OF MARCH
TWENTY EIGHT THROUGH THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE COURT. MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO MOVE ON TO CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE. THE SECOND
READING FILE PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN SIXTY WITH
AMENDMENTS NINE TWENTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS ELEVEN THIRTY ONE
WITH AMENDMENTS AT NINE THIRTY
FOUR WITH AMENDMENTS NINE SIXTY
SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS NINE SIXTY
FOUR WITH AMENDMENTS FOURTEEN
SEVENTY NINE WITH AMENDMENTS TEN
OH EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS THE
SECOND READING WILL BE DEEMED
READ. WILL MOVE ON TO UNFINISHED
BUSINESS. MOVING TO ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY
FOUR SENATOR UMBERG. HE IS
PREPARED PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE FORTY NINE BY SENATOR%
UMBERG AN ACT RELATING TO
SUBSTANCE ABUSE CENTER AMBER IN
THE FORAGERS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS- SB THREE
FORTY NINE THE CALIFORNIA
ETHICAL TREATMENT FOR PERSONS
WITH SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDER.
ACT IS BACK ON CONCURRENCE MEN'S
TAKE IN THE ASSEMBLY TO
REORGANIZE THE BILL SO THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES CAN BETTER IMPLEMENT IT
MAKES OTHER CLARIFYING CHANGES-
TONIGHT BOTH. FOR ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
NINE BOTTOM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA
HI I ATKINS AYE BATES AYE BECKER
AYE FORGES. BRADFORD CABALLERO I
PROTECTING AYE DALY. DODD HI
TORONTO I EGGMAN I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG I
REQUEST SO. HI FURTADO'S. JONES. KAMLAGER I CLEARED. I LEYVA I
LIMÓN AYE MCGUIRE. I MELENDEZ
FIVE MIN AYE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN
. I UNTIL ABOUT AYE PAN. I
PORTANTINO HI ROTH AYE RUBIO. I
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE AMBERG AYE
WHAT KASKY I WIENER AYE WILK.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN I. PORCHES BRADFORD. DALLY
I GLAZER I GROVE. FOR TADO.
JONES I WILL. I THIRTY FIVE NO
ZERO THE AMENDMENT TO THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN MOVING ON THE
SENATE THIRD READING WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY THREE. SENATOR NIELSEN.
HE IS PREPARED. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION EIGHTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR NIELSEN RELATIVE TO
ENROLLED AGENTS DAY. CENTER
NIELSEN THE FLOOR IS YOURS NOT A
PRESIDENT AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN OF THE SENATE IRITIS
THIS AFTERNOON TO PRESENT AS SHE
- EIGHTY SEVEN RECOGNIZING APRIL
FIFTEENTH. TWENTY TWENTY TWO IS
ENROLLED AGENTS DAY IN
CALIFORNIA. FEDERAL AGENTS FOR
DECADES THE BEEN THE EFFECTIVE
ADMINISTRATORS WORKING TOGETHER
WITH FEDERAL AND STATE TAX
AGENCIES HELPING OUR TAXPAYERS
COMPLY WITH THE COMPLEX. AND
CONFUSING TAX COACH. SINCE
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FOR THE
PREVENTIVE THIS PROFESSION WAS
FORMALLY CREATED. AT THE END OF
THE CIVIL WAR TO ROOM REPRESENTS
CITIZENS BEFORE THE US TREASURY
DEPARTMENT. TO NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE WITH THE CREATION OF THE
AMERICAN SOCIETY OF CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY EXCUSE ME OF ENROLLED
AGENTS. UP TILL TODAY ROLLED
AGENCIES TAXPAYERS ANY TYPE OF
BUSINESS ENTITY. WITH THE ANNUAL
AND PERIODIC COMPLIANCE
REQUIRED. FOR FILING THEIR TAX
RETURNS. ON THESE VERY COMPLEX.
TAXATION ON LEVERAGE THE PEELS
MEANS IN COLOR AND COULD CORRECT
CORRECTIONS EXCUSE ME. THEIR
KNOWLEDGE PROFESSIONALISM AND
INTEGRITY MAKE THE ENROLLED
AGENTS. ERICA'S TAX EXPERTS.
THEY DESERVE TO BE RECOGNIZED
AND WE DO SO. WITH THIS
RESOLUTION SCR. EIGHTY SEVEN. I
ASK IN MY BOOK. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
THANK NINE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN FIVE
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES I
BAKER. HI FORGES. BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO AYE PROTESTING AYE
DOLLY AYE DODD I TORONTO. EGGMAN. GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH I
HERTZBERG I REQUEST SO. I
FURTADO I JONES I KAMLAGER I
LAYERED FIVE LEYVA I LIMÓN.
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ AYE MIN AYE
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN AYE TELEVOTE
AYE PAN. I PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN. HI
NUMBER HI WHITE HOUSE SKI. I
WIENER AYE WILK. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS FORGES. TORONTO
HI EGGMAN I LIMÓN I WELL. FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT SENATOR
UMBERG IS READY PLEASE READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
EIGHTY FIVE BY SENATOR ON BURKE
RELATIVE TO BLACK APRIL MEMORIAL
MONTH. SENATOR AMBER THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS COLLEAGUES
I HAVE THE HONOR OF REPRESENTING
THE THIRTY FOURTH SENATORIAL
DISTRICT WHICH INCLUDES THE
LARGEST VIETNAMESE COMMUNITY
OUTSIDE VIETNAM APRIL THIRTIETH
NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE MARKS THE
END OF ONE THE MOST DEVASTATING
MODERN COMPLEX ONE LONG IS
COMPLEX THE VIETNAM WAR. BLACK
APRIL IS A TIME OF MOURNING A
TIME REMEMBRANCE AND NOT JUST
THE LIVES LOST DURING THE WAR
BUT THE LIES OF VIETNAMESE
PEOPLE IN THEIR HISTORIC
STRUGGLE FOR FREEDOM. AND HUMAN
RIGHTS- WE WISH TO OBSERVE. THIS
DAY. THIS MONTH AS A REMEMBRANCE
OF NOT ONLY TRAGIC LOSS BUT ALSO
A CELEBRATION OF THE VIETNAMESE
PEOPLE'S RESILIENCE AND STRENGTH
TO PROSPER IN THE FACE OF
ADVERSITY. THE LATE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES TO MID NINETEEN
EIGHTIES AN ESTIMATED FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND VIETNAMESE
PEOPLE RISK THEIR LIVES. BY
FLEEING VIETNAM ABOARD SMALL
BOATS IN A MASS EXODUS. IS
IMMIGRANTS REACH REFUGEE CAMPS
IN THAILAND MALAYSIA INDONESIA.
THE PHILIPPINES JAPAN AND HONG
KONG. ABOUT ONE HALF OF THE
PEOPLE FLEEING VIETNAM. IN
SEARCH OF FREEDOM AND DEMOCRACY
PERISHED AT SEA. VIETNAMESE
AMERICAN REFUGEES SOON BECAME A
PART. OF A CONTINUE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO AMERICA AND IN
PARTICULAR CALIFORNIA'S
DIVERSITY CULTURE. AND THE
ECONOMY TWENTY UNITED STATES
CENSUS IN TWENTY TWENTY MORE
THAN TWO POINT ONE MILLION
VIETNAMESE LIVE IN THE UNITED
STATES AND SIX HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND LIVE IN CALIFORNIA. THE
LARGEST CONCENTRATION FOUND IN
ORANGE COUNTY. SANTA CLARA
COUNTY THERE IN SAN DIEGO. THIS
RESOLUTION COMMEMORATES THE
LIVES OF OUR SOLDIERS FROM THE
REPUBLIC OF VIETNAM IN AMERICA
HONORS THE VETERANS IS SACRIFICE
THEIR YOU FOR THE IDEAL OF
FREEDOM. AND DEMOCRACY AND
RECOGNIZE THE CIVILIANS OF
SHOWING THE RESILIENCY
OVERCOMING THE TRAUMAS OF WAR.
WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO ASK THAT
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA SET
ASIDE A MOMENT EVERY YEAR ON
APRIL THIRTIETH. THE GIVE
REMEMBRANCE TO THE SOLDIERS
MEDICAL PERSONNEL AND CIVILIANS
WHO SACRIFICE THEIR LIVES DURING
THE VIETNAM WAR. PURSUIT OF
FREEDOM AND DEMOCRACY. MONTH OF
APRIL TWENTY TWENTY TWO SHALL BE
PROCLAIMED AS BLACK APRIL
MEMORIAL MONTH AS WE HOPE FOR
MORE JUSTICE AND LIBERTY FOR THE
PEOPLE OF VIETNAM I URGE AND I
BOTH. THANK YOU. SENATOR PER TV. I WANT TO A RISE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT ARISES
SUPPORT OF S. C. R. EIGHTY FIVE-
ON BEHALF OF THE ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND PLUS VIETNAMESE
AMERICANS- IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY
THE MAJORITY OF WHICH ARE IN
SENATE DISTRICT FIFTEEN- IN- THE
BALANCE OF WHICH OF
PREDOMINATELY- LIVE IN MY
COLLEAGUES DISTRICT FROM THE
CITY OF FREMONT- THAT SAID-
THESE ARE REFUGEES MANY OF WHOM
ARE STILL FIRST GENERATION- WHO
ARE VIEWED AS THE GREATEST
GENERATION OF THEIR DEMOCRACY
AND CONTINUE TO THIS DAY THE
STAND FOR FREEDOM HUMAN RIGHTS
AND DEMOCRACY IN THE WORLD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I URGE AN
AYE VOTE. SENATOR TO LETTER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I RISE IS
THE CHAIR OF THE MILITARY
VETERANS COMMITTEE AND I
ACKNOWLEDGE OUR SENATOR FROM
ORANGE COUNTY FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. FIFTY EIGHT THOUSAND
OVER FIFTY EIGHT THOUSAND
AMERICAN LIVES LOST. AND CAN YOU
IMAGINE THE NUMBER OF VIETNAMESE
WHO WERE OFTENTIMES SIDE BY SIDE
BY OUR TROOPS WHO ALSO LOST
THEIR LIVES AND ONE DAY TRYING
TO FIND FREEDOM AND HOPE. IN
THOSE WHO WERE ABLE TO COME TO
AMERICA WHO RECEIVED A WELCOME
BY SO MANY VETERANS AND TIME
AFTER TIME. VISITING ORANGE
COUNTY TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
VETERANS THAT ARE THERE THE
VIETNAMESE AMERICANS NOW WHO
HAVE BECOME AMERICAN CITIZENS
THAT HAVE CONTRIBUTED SO MUCH TO
ORANGE COUNTY AND TO AMERICA
LAKE KNOWLEDGE THEIR SERVICE I'D
KNOWLEDGE THOSE. WHO HAVE
SACRIFICED BRING PEACE TO US
HERE IN AMERICA ALWAYS
ACKNOWLEDGE- MEN AND WOMEN IN
UNIFORM AND I URGE EVERYONE TO
SUPPORT. S. C. R. EIGHTY FIVE
AND I THANK YOU. BETTER DRAWS A
- THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
JUST WANT TO ADD ON TOP OF THE
COMMENTS MADE BY MY COLLEAGUES-
A PERSONAL PART OF ME WHICH IS
MY BROTHER SERVED IN VIETNAM WAS
INJURED CAME BACK AND LUCKILY
WAS ABLE TO GET THROUGH HIS
PHYSICAL INJURIES- STILL LIVES
WITH THE TRAUMA OF SUCH A
TERRIBLE WAR SO I JUST WANT TO
ADD ON BEHALF OF OUR FAMILY NOT
ONLY TO EVERYONE WHO SERVED OVER
THERE. BUT TO MY BROTHER ON THE
PHONE SO THE REST OF. SENATOR
PAN. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATOR SORRY TO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF S. R. EIGHTY FIVE AND ONE TO
THANK MY GOOD FRIEND FROM ORANGE
COUNTY FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- AS CHAIR THE H. I.
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. THE VIETNAM
WAR SACRAMENTO IS IMPACT- NOT
ONLY ON THIS COUNTRY BUT OF
COURSE- ON MANY OF THE- REFUGEES
WHO CAME FROM VIETNAM TO COME
HERE TO OUR COUNTRY AND FROM
OTHER- ACTUALLY SURROUNDING
AREAS AS WELL. SO IT'S IMPORTANT
TO REMEMBER THAT WE REMEMBER
THIS HISTORY- THAT REMEMBER THE
SACRIFICES THAT WERE MADE THERE
BUT ALSO THE FACT THAT SO MANY.
PEOPLE BECAUSE OF. OUR ACTIONS
THERE DID COME TO OUR COUNTRY
AND- TO SPEAK- FREEDOM AND
OPPORTUNITY AND WE NEED TO BE
SURELY REMEMBER THAT HISTORY
THANK YOU. IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
RESOLUTION ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
THAT CENTER AMBURGEY MAKE
INCLUDE- THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR IMPORTANT
CONTRIBUTIONS. THE VIETNAM WAR'S
LEGACY CONTINUES TODAY- IN IT IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE- NOT JUST VIETNAMESE
AMERICANS BUT ALL YOUNG PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND THE COURAGE AND
SACRIFICE OF PARTICULARLY THOSE
WHO FLED VIETNAM AND THEIR
LEGACY HERE IN THE UNITED STATES
SURGEON AYE VOTE. RENDON
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS
AYE BATES AYE BACKER I FOR JUST
FIVE BRADFORD AYE CABRERA AYE
CORTESE AYE DOLLY. I DODD. I
THROSSELL I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH. I
HERTZBERG AYE WESTERN. I FURTADO
I JONES I KAMLAGER I LAYERED AYE
LEYVA AYE MON AYE MCGUIRE. I
MELENDEZ AYE MIN I NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN I PROVOKE I CAN HI
PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO. I
SKINNER I STERN AYE NUMBER HI MY
COUNTY I WIENER AYE WILK. FIVE
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. MEMBERS
UNDER PRIVILEGES AT THE FLOOR WE
HAVE SOME GUESTS IN THE GALLERY
IF YOU COULD PLEASE RISE THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY CYNTHIA ZIMMER
FROM KERN COUNTY. ALONG WITH THE
DEATH THE PERKINS AND A DEATH
SAYS ON T. DRIVE ON BEHALF OF
CENTER GROVE IN THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE WE WELCOME YOU TO
THE CHAMBER. THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US AS WE DO OUR
BUSINESS. MEMBERS ARE MOVING UP-
WE'RE GOING BACK TO SENATE THIRD
READING ITEM NUMBER FORTY WHICH
IS SENATOR MAN. HE IS READY
PLEASE READ. SENATE RESOLUTION
FORTY FIVE BY SENATOR MEN
RELATIVE TO ACADEMIC FREEDOM
CENTER MEN THE FOR YEARS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE TO
PRESENT SENATE RESOLUTION FORTY
FIVE WHICH- RECOGNIZES THAT
ACADEMIC FREEDOM IN OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS. FOR
COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY
PROFESSORS IS CRUCIAL FOR
FOSTERING HEALTHY DISCOURSE IN
THIS. IN OUR CLASSROOMS I DON'T
THINK IT'S AN EXAGGERATION TO
SAY THAT. CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS ARE THE
BEDROCK OF OUR ECONOMY OF OUR
SOCIETY- THEY'RE CONSIDERED A
TOOL AROUND THE WORLD. AND AT
THE HEART OF HIGHER EDUCATION I
SPEAK AS A LAW PROFESSOR SOMEONE
WHO IS TUGHT IN THE CLASSROOM
IS THE IDEA OF ACADEMIC
INDEPENDENCE AND FREEDOM. OUR
CLASSROOMS WOULD NOT BE AS
ROBUST IF WE DID NOT HAVE THAT
TYPE OF DIALOGUE- IT WE HAVE TO
HAVE A CLASSROOM WHERE WE CAN
HAVE A SETTING. I'M SORRY- WHERE
WHERE WE CAN ENCOURAGE
CHALLENGING ONE'S ASSUMPTIONS
AND BELIEFS ABOUT THE WORLD- YOU
CAN'T REALLY DO THAT WITHOUT
ACADEMIC FREEDOM AND
INDEPENDENCE. HI IT'S S. R.
FORTY FIVE RECOGNIZES THE
IMPORTANCE OF ENSURING ACADEMIC.
FREEDOM FOR COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSITY PROFESSORS INCLUDING
IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
THIS RESOLUTION IS SPONSORED BY
THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I'VE-
SENATOR MELINDA. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- I HAVE A QUESTION OF
THE AUTHOR IF I MAY. YOU MAY OR
AYE PROCEDURALLY MADAM PRESIDENT. OKAY AT W. TAKE A QUESTION
CENTERMAN- YES THEY WILL BE WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH- AS SENATOR
MAN WOULD YOU BE WILLING AS THIS
BILL MOVES FORWARD TO AMEND YOUR
BILL ARE TO SUPPORT A LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCY POLICY
PROHIBITING DISCRIMINATION BASED
UPON OUR STUDENTS POLITICAL
AFFILIATION SO INCLUDING
STUDENTS WITHIN YOUR RESOLUTION
AND NOT JUST THE FACULTY. I
THINK THIS BILL READY GO OUT I'D
BE HAPPY TO CONSIDER A SEPARATE
RESOLUTION ABOUT STUDENT VIEWS
AS WELL. NO NO THEN. ARE NOT
WITHIN YOUR BILL WELL THIS BILL
IS A I DON'T THINK WE WANT TO
LIKE INCLUDE A LOT OF AMENDMENTS
AT THIS POINT BUT- I'D BE HAPPY
TO CONSIDER SUPPORTING
RESOLUTION IF YOU LIKE TO OFFER
ONE. ON STUDENT VISAS. BUT
THAT'S NOT REALLY THE GOAL OF
THIS PARTICULAR OKAY WELL I AM
SO HAPPY TO HEAR THAT- BECAUSE I
RISE IN A BIT OF CONFUSION ABOUT
THE MERITS OF THIS RESOLUTION.
AND WHAT IT SAYS TO OUR STUDENTS
AND THE PARENTS- WHEN IT. YOU
KNOW WHAT WE'RE ALLOWING IN IN
OUR UNIVERSITIES WHEN IT COMES
TO CONTROVERSY ALL SUBJECT
MATTER IN OUR SCHOOLS AS
PARENTS. WE SEND OUR KIDS TO
SCHOOL TO BE EDUCATED. NOT
INDOCTRINATED. IN S. R. FORTY
FIVE. AS I UNDERSTAND AIMS TO
PROTECT TEACHERS FROM.
RETRIBUTION FROM EXPRESSING
VIEWPOINTS THAT MIGHT BE
CONSIDERED CONTROVERSIAL IN THE
CLASSROOM- WHETHER BY STUDENTS
OR THE ADMINISTRATORS. AND
THAT'S A- LAUDABLE EFFORT I
WOULD SAY BUT IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WE AT HARVARD STUDENTS
. WHO ACTIVELY TRIED TO PREVENT
ANY CURRENT OR FORMER. BUT
MINISTRATION OFFICIAL FROM
APPEARING AS A SPEAKER ON THE
CAMPUS OF KEEPING OTHER STUDENTS
FROM HEARING A MESSAGE THAT THEY
MIGHT BE INTERESTED IN BASED ON
THE FACT THAT THEY FOUND THE%
ELEMENTS OF THE CONVERSATION
MIGHT BE TO CONTROVERSY. SO I'M
JUST WONDERING WHAT KIND OF
DOUBLE STANDARD WE ARE
ENCOURAGING HERE BECAUSE ON THE
ONE HAND WE WANT TO PROTECT
TEACHERS IN ANY VIEW POINTS THAT
THEY MAY WISH TO EXPRESS IN THE
CLASSROOM WHETHER. SOMEONE
AGREES WITH IT OR NOT BUT ON THE
OTHER HAND WE'RE NOT PROTECTING
STUDENTS AS WELL- THAT WAS THE
BILL ACTUALLY WAS MY BILLS I'M
HAPPY TO HEAR YOU WOULD SUPPORT
A RESOLUTION THAT WOULD PROTECT
STUDENTS IT WAS S. B. TWO FORTY
NINE IT WAS VOTED DOWN IN
COMMITTEE SO I WOULD JUST REMIND
EVERYONE AGAIN. THAT- AS THE
SAYING GOES WHAT'S GOOD FOR THE
GOOSE IS GOOD FOR THE GANDER AND
IF WE ARE GOING TO PROTECT OUR
TEACHERS. AND OUR- FACULTY IN
UNIVERSITIES STUDENTS SHOULD BE
PROTECTED AS WELL THERE SEEMS TO
BE A DISPARITY HERE AND WHAT THE
STATE THE MESSAGE OF THE STATE
IS SENDING. OUT TO OUR
UNIVERSITY SO WITH THAT SAID- I
WILL NOT BE VOTING FOR THIS
RESOLUTION TODAY BECAUSE I
THINK. IT'S NOT. IT'S NOT
COMPLETE. YOU KNOW THE
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE IS
TEACHERS AND STUDENTS. THIS IS
NOT A COMPLETE PACKAGE SO
BECAUSE OF THOSE REASONS THOUGH
I. UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO AND I SUPPORT PEOPLE
HAVING THE FREEDOM OF SPEECH IN
THE CLASSROOM. IT'S JUST I WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THE STUDENTS HAVE
THE SAME FREEDOM OF SPEECH THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. UNDER
EGGMAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BUT
CENTER PAN AM I'M WONDERING AS
AS SOMEBODY WAS ALSO A CLASSROOM
PROFESSOR A TENURE CLASSROOM
PROFESSOR- AND THE PURPOSE OF
ACADEMIC FREEDOM AND TENURE
HISTORICALLY CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG IS SO THAT WHEN PEOPLE
WERE TEACHING SOMETHING THAT
MIGHT BE OUTSIDE- SEE SAY THE
MOORS THE- THE GOVERNMENT AS IT
WERE BECAUSE OUR ACADEMIC.
LEGACIES CAME FROM OTHER PLACES
WHERE PEOPLE DIDN'T HAVE THE
FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION OR THE
FREEDOM OF THOUGHT AND COULD BE
FIRED FOR SAYING SOMETHING THAT
MIGHT BE. NOT NOT A LONG LINE
WITH THE CHURCH OR NOT ALIGNED
WITH SOMETHING ELSE. AND YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THIS IS ACADEMIC
FREEDOM AT THE FACULTY FOR
COLLEGE LEVELS RIGHT TO THESE
PEOPLE BY DEFINITION ARE NOT
CHILDREN BUT ARE IT PROBABLY AT
LEAST EIGHTEEN MAYBE THERE'S A
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD BRIGHT PERSON
IN THERE OR EVEN UP TO. THIS TO
SIXTY OR SIXTY FIVE RIGHT SO AND
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THE
STUDENTS AND WILLINGLY WENT TO
CLASS SIGNED UP FOR THE CLASS IS
GOING TO THE CLASS BEFORE YOUR
BILL IS TRYING TO DO IS LIKE
REDEFINE OR RE VERIFY. THAT
FACULTY MEMBERS WHO ARE TEACHING
IN A DESIGN SUBJECT MATTER THAT
THEY ARE OFTENTIMES HAVE A PHD
IN WOULD BE FREE TO BE ABLE TO
TEACH THAT THE STUDENTS TO THEIR
FULL ABILITY. AND IT'S ALSO
ABOUT MAINTAINING THEIR
EMPLOYMENT NOT ABOUT THEIR
OPTION TO TAKE A CLASS OR NOT
WHEN THEY CHOOSE TO GO TO A
UNIVERSITY TO BECOME A STUDENT
IS THAT CORRECT. SENATOR MEN
WILL YOU TAKE A QUESTION I WILL
TAKE THE QUESTION. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION- CENTER EGGMAN. SOB
YES I THE GOAL OF DISABILITIES
INCLUDED TWO IS TO. REAFFIRM OUR
COMMITMENT ECONOMIC FREEDOM AND
BY THAT I DON'T JUST MEAN HAVING
CONTROVERSIAL VIEW. BUT BEING
ABLE TO EXPRESS CONTROVERSIAL
STATEMENTS TO TEACH
CONTROVERSIAL SUBJECTS. WITHOUT
FEAR OF CONSEQUENCES WITHOUT
FEAR OF POLITICALLY MOTIVATED
RETRIBUTION. WHICH WE'VE SEEN
FAR TOO OFTEN IN RECENT MONTHS
AND YEARS. I ANSWER THIS IS
PARTICULARLY PERNICIOUS AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL BECAUSE
MANY THAT FACULTY COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. DON'T HAVE THE TYPE OF
JOB SECURITY. THAT THEIR UC AND
CSU TENURE COUNTERPART DO. AND
AGAIN I WOULD JUST EMPHASIZE TO
MY COLLEAGUE- WE SPOKE EARLIER
THAT- THIS IS ABOUT HOW WE
FOSTER HEALTHY DIALOGUE AND I'M
GLAD WE'RE HAVING THIS DIALOGUE
BECAUSE THIS IS AN EXAMPLE. OF
THE TYPE OF DIALOGUE THAT THAT
WE LIKE TO PROMOTE AND IN
CLASSROOMS I THINK IT SAID.
AGAIN AT THE BEDROCK OF AMERICAN
HIGHER EDUCATION. THIS IDEA THAT
WE CAN HAVE A HEALTHY
DISCUSSION. OF CONFLICTING
VIEWS. AT BUT FOR THAT TO HAPPEN
THE PROFESSOR THE PERSON LEADING
THAT DISCUSSION. HAS TO FEEL
FREE TO BE ABLE TO EXPRESS
THOSE. OPINIONS TO BE ABLE TO
CONDUCT THAT DIALOGUE WITHOUT
FEAR. THAT SOME CLIP IS GOING TO
GET OUT ON THE INTERNET THAT'S
GOING TO CAUSE THEM TO LOSE
THEIR JOBS AND THAT THAT'S
REALLY WHAT THIS BILL IS ABOUT-
AND AGAIN I FEAR THAT. I THINK
THE VALUES ARE EXPRESSED EARLIER
ABOUT HAVING OPPOSING VIEWPOINTS
ABOUT HAVING CONTROVERSIAL
VIEWS. ABOUT THIS TALKING ABOUT
SOMEBODY YOU KNOW NOT BEING ABLE
DO SOMETHING WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SOMEONE LOSING THEIR LIVELIHOOD
BECAUSE THEY EXPRESS
CONTROVERSIAL POSITION. ANY
FURTHER. OR DEBATE. PHENTERMINE
CAN WE ACCEPT THAT AS YOUR
CLOTHES YES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. BAKER I PORCHES.
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE FOR
THIRTY FIVE DALLY. DODD I
TORONTO. I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I WROTE. HERTZBERG I
WESTERN HI FOR TIGER. I JONES.
KAMLAGER I LAYERED I LEYVA I
LIMON AYE MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ.
MANY AYE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN. I A
TROUBLED. PAN I PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH I RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN I
AM BURKE HI WHAT HOUSE HE- I
WIENER. AYE WILK PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. FACE FORTUS.
DALLY GROVE. JONES MELENDEZ BUT
TROUBLED WELL. I THIRTY TWO
KNOWS ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE
ON TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR. WITH
ANY MEMBER LIKE A ITEM ON
CONSENT. TO BE LIFTED OFF. F. AS
SENATOR- TROUBLE. FORTIFICATIONS
I NEED A BILL REMOVED BUT I'M I
BELIEVE IT'S UNDER. IF YOU COULD
GIVE US THE BILL NUMBER. MORRELL
S. OR YEAH.
OKAY OKAY. OKAY AFTER READING
ALL THE WRONG WITH THAT. SO
THERE IS NO ITEM TO BE TAKEN
THERE IS NO MOTION TO TAKE
ANYTHING OFF THE CONSENT
CALENDAR- IT'S ITEM NUMBER SIXTY
ONE. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
THE ITEMS ON CONSENT. SENATE
BILL ELEVEN NINETY TWO. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BAKER I FOR JUST. I BRADFORD
AYE CABALLERO AYE PROTESTING AYE
DOLLY AYE DODD. I DRAW SO I
EGGMAN AYE GLAZER. I GONZALEZ I
GROW. HERTZBERG I WESTERN. I
FURTADO I JONES I KAMLAGER FIVE
LAYERED HI LEYVA FIVE THE MON I
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ FIVE
MILLION I NEWMAN. I NIELSEN.
OTOBO I AM I PORTANTINO I ROTH
AYE RUBIO. I SKINNER I STERN HI
I'M BURKE AYE BY CAL SKI HI
WIENER. I WILL. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GROVE I NIELSEN
I WILK. FIVE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED
. MEMBERS ARE GOING TO GO BACK
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
OPPORTUNITY SENATE RULE TWENTY
NINE POINT TEN D. THE FOLLOWING
BILLS ARE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON RULES ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE S. B. TWO OH SEVEN.
SENATOR TROUBLED. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. UNDER THE MOTIONS A
RESOLUTION WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT SB
NINE THIRTY SEVEN FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR PURPOSES OF
AMENDMENTS PLEASE. SO ORDERED.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS. SENATOR
CORTESE EVER COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENT. YES THE CITY OF
SENATE LABOR COMMITTEE WILL
MEET- TWENTY MINUTES AFTER
ADJOURNMENT TODAY NO SOONER THAN
AND WE'RE TRYING TO GET A START
AS CLOSE THREE **** POSSIBLE
THANK YOU IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED OVER IN- ST. OKAY CENTER
CASEY THE LABOR COMMITTEE WILL
MEET IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
ON THE- STREET SENATOR REID.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THE
SENATE BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
WILL RECONVENE TWENTY MINUTES.
AFTER SUCH IN THE CHAMBER AFTER
SESSION SENATE CONCLUDES. NOTED
THE P. AND E. D. HERE IN THE
CHAMBER TWENTY MINUTES AFTER
SESSION. READ RETURNING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS MEMBERS
IF YOU COULD PLEASE TAKE YOUR
SEATS WERE READY TO- DO A COUPLE
OF ADJOURN IN. I IN MEMORY.
SENATOR LEYVA. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS IT IS WITH
GREAT SADNESS THAT I ASKED WE
ADJOURN TODAY IN THE MEMORY OF
DR TOM RIVERA DR VEER GREW UP IN
SOUTH COLTON AND GRADUATED FROM
COLTON SCHOOLS SAN MARINO VALLEY
COLLEGE AND CAPPED HIS EDUCATION
WITH A DOCTORATE DEGREE FROM
UCLA HE WAS AN ADMINISTRATOR AT
CAL STATE SAN MARINO FOR NEARLY
FORTY YEARS. DR RIVERA WAS A
PILLAR OF THE INLAND EMPIRE AND
LIVED A LIFE OF SERVICE IN HIS
COMMUNITY HE SERVED ON THE
BOARDS OF THE RIALTO TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION UNITED WAY EASTER
SEAL SOCIETY OMNITRANS CATHOLIC
CHARITIES AND ROLLING START
AFTER BEING ELECTED TO THE
COLTON JOINT UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT BOARD OF TRUSTEES HE
HAS ALSO SERVED ON THE SAN
MARINO COUNTY BI LINGUAL TASK
FORCE WAS HAMMERED IN A VALLEY
COLLEGE E. O. P. S. THE SAMBAR
DINO DRUG AND GANG TASK FORCE.
THE CHANCELLOR'S CHICANO
ADVISORY COMMITTEE AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE THE BOYS AND GIRLS
CLUB OF AMERICA AND SISTER
CITIES INTERNATIONAL MEXICALI
VIA HERMOSA WHEN HE RETIRED FROM
CSU B. AND TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN
HE WAS COMMENDED FOR HIS NEARLY
FIFTY YEARS IN THE FIELD OF
EDUCATION THROUGHOUT THE INLAND
EMPIRE ONE OF HIS LASTING
CONTRIBUTIONS WAS THE CREATION
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE OF THE
INLAND EMPIRE FUTURE LEADERS HE
LOVED THAT PROGRAM ESPECIALLY
WORKING WITH MIDDLE SCHOOL KIDS
FROM THE INLAND EMPIRE. SINCE
THEN MORE THAN FORTY FOUR
HUNDRED STUDENTS HAVE COMPLETED
THE PROGRAM AND GRADUATES
INCLUDE TWO MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
REPRESENTED PETE AGUILAR FROM
SAN MARINO REPRESENTATIVE RAUL
RUIZ FROM PALM DESERT AS WELL AS
EDUCATORS DOCTORS LAWYERS AND
NONPROFIT FOUNDERS HIS EFFORTS
TO UPLIFT HIS COMMUNITY AND GROW
FUTURE LEADERS ACROSS THE INLAND
EMPIRE IN CALIFORNIA WILL
CONTINUE FOR GENERATIONS TO COME
I HAD MANY INTERACTIONS WITH DR
RIVERA AND I ALWAYS LOVED AND
APPRECIATE DID. HIS TO THE
STUDENTS TO THE REGION HE WAS
ALWAYS UP HE WAS ALWAYS POSITIVE
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE LILY.
DAUGHTER PATRICE VIA FUND TOM
AND HIS BROTHER RAY RIVERA AS
WELL AS SEVERAL GRANDCHILDREN.
THE MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
JOURNEY TODAY IN THE MEMORY OF
DR TOM RIVERA. PLEASE BRING HIS
NAME TO THE DESK SO THAT HE CAN
BE PER PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY
THE SENATE. SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
TODAY TO TURN THE MEMORY OF ONE
OF MY CONSTITUENTS FROM LONG
BEACH BERMAN MEL BRUMMEL STEAM
BELL MERMELSTEIN WAS A HOLOCAUST
SURVIVOR VETERAN OF THE US ARMY
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
AUTOBIOGRAPHER. IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE IS LAWSUIT IN LOS
ANGELES SUPERIOR COURT BECAME
THE FIRST TIME FOR THE UNITED
STATES RULED THAT THE EXISTENCE
OF THE HOLOCAUST. WAS A LEGALLY
NON CONTESTABLE FACT. NO MORAL
STEAM WAS BORN IN CZECHOSLOVAKIA
ON SEPTEMBER TWENTY FIVE
NINETEEN TWENTY SIX TO A JEWISH
FAMILY WAS ONE OF FOUR CHILDREN.
WHEN HE WAS SEVENTEEN THE ****
FORCED MELLON'S FAMILY LEAVE
THEIR HOME MOVING TO GHETTOS
BEFORE BEING TAKEN TO AUSCHWITZ.
WHEN THEY ARRIVED AT THE
CONCENTRATION CAMP HIS MOTHER
WAS SENT TO THE GAS CHAMBER. AND
HIS SISTERS RAN TO THE MOTHER'S
SIDE ALL THREE PAIRS. LATER'S
FATHER AND BROTHER WERE MURDERED
BY THE **** LEAVING MEL IS THE
FAMILY'S SOLE SURVIVOR. THE
SOVIETS NEAR THE CAMP THE -(***
FORCED MELANIE OTHER OCCUPANTS
TO BEGIN A THREE WEEK. HUNDRED
FIFTY FIVE MILE DEATH MARCH TO
GROSS ROSEN. CONCENTRATION CAMP
WHERE THEY WERE LOADED. ONTO A
TRAIN FOR THE BOOK INVOLVED
CONCENTRATION CAMP. ON OCTOBER
EXCUSE ME APRIL ELEVENTH
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE AMERICAN
SOLDIERS LIBERATED BUCHENWALD
BELL WAS EIGHTEEN YEARS OLD
WEIGHED SIXTY EIGHT POUNDS.
AFTER RECEIVING MEDICAL
TREATMENT HE DISCOVERED SOMEONE
ELSE NOW LIVING IN THE FAMILY'S
HOME WE LEFT THE UNITED STATES
WITHOUT KNOWING A WORD OF
ENGLISH TO LIVE WITH A IN AN
UNCLE IN NEW YORK. AFTER
BECOMING A NATURALIZED CITIZEN
MEL WAS DRAFTED THE US ARMY AND
SERVED IN ARMY INTELLIGENCE
DURING THE KOREAN WAR AND LATER
WAS A TRANSLATOR. AND FOR THE
UNITED NATIONS. AFTER SERVICE
WAS CONCLUDED BILL AUTHORED HIS
MEMOIRS RECOUNTING HIS
EXPERIENCES IN THE CONCENTRATION
CAMPS. HE MET HIS WIFE. EMMA
JAMES NANCE IN NINETEEN SIXTY
MOVED TO LOS ANGELES IN NINETEEN
SIXTY ONE TO START THEIR FAMILY
. STARTED MANUFACTURING COMPANY
THAT MADE WOODEN PALLETS
EMPLOYING GENERATIONS OF WORKERS
. MELL BEGAN TO TRAVEL BACK TO
AUSCHWITZ AND OTHER NEARBY CAMPS
IN NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN
FOLLOWING THE SIX DAY WAR HE
BECAME DETERMINED TO ENSURE THE
EVIDENCE OF WHAT HAPPENED TO HIS
FAMILY IN THE MILLIONS OF OTHER
JEWS AND OTHERS- WHO WERE KILLED
BY THE **** THAT THAT MEMORY WAS
NOT LOST THEY'LL BEGIN SPEAKING
TO CLASSROOMS AND SCHOOL
ASSEMBLIES TO EDUCATE STUDENTS
AND TEACHERS. WHAT EXPERIENCE
AND WOOD COUNTY STUDENTS THOSE
WITH. READING THE MESSAGE OF
PEACE HOPE RECONCILIATION AND
RESILIENCE AS LONG AS WELL- IS
HE POSSIBLY COULD COULD LEARNING
FROM. THE HISTORY OF SUCH A DARK
PERIOD. NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
THE INSTITUTE FOR HISTORICAL
REVIEW OFFERED A FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR REWARD FOR EVIDENCE THAT
THE HOLOCAUST ACTUALLY HAPPENED
. AFTER WRITING A LETTER TO THE
EDITOR OF THE PUBLICATION THAT
PUBLICATION BEGIN TO TARGET MEL
MEL TOOK THE PUBLICATION ACCORD
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE WINNING A
STORY CASE THE JUDGE THE
JUDICIAL OF JUDICIAL NOTICE OF
THE FACT THAT JEWS WERE KILLED
THE GAS CHAMBERS AT AUSCHWITZ.
AND OTHER CAMPS MANY OF THE
CRIMES OF THE **** WERE FACT.
THE COULD NOT REASONABLY BE
SUBJECT TO DISPUTE. THROUGHOUT
HIS JOURNEYS TO AUSCHWITZ
MILITATE ARTIFACTS AND OTHER
ITEMS SUCH AS UNIFORMS PIECES OF
FENCING AND EVEN PARTS OF THE
JEWISH PRAYERBOOK. HE FOUND
BURIED NEAR INCINERATOR. RATING
EXHIBIT. ON HIS OWN PROPERTY
WERE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS TOWARD IS EXHIBIT FOR
FREE. THROUGH COLLABORATION
BETWEEN OUTFITS. THE US WOULD
STUDY FOUNDATION A NONPROFIT
MILL FOUNDED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT. AND THE COBOT JEWISH
CENTER IN NEWPORT BEACH THE
ORANGE COUNTY HOLOCAUST
EDUCATION CENTER. ALL THOSE
ENTITIES WILL HOUSE SMELLS
COLLECTION SO THAT STUDENTS
TEACHERS THE PUBLIC CONTINUE TO
HAVE ACCESS. NOW PASSED AWAY ON
JANUARY TWENTY EIGHT TWENTY
TWENTY TWO IS HOME IN LONG
BEACH. HE WAS NINETY FIVE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE JEAN. THIS
CHILDREN BERNIE EDDIE CAN AND
DAVID FIVE GRANDCHILDREN AND ONE
GREAT GRANDCHILD. A. S. THAT WE
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF THIS
AMAZING HUMAN BEING. PLEASE
BRING HIS NAME FORWARD TO THE
DESK SO THAT THE SENATE MAY
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE HIM.
MEMBERS IF THERE'S NO OTHER
BUSINESS SENATOR ACTIONS THE
DESK IT'S CLEAR. WELL THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT OUR NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR THIS
THURSDAY APRIL SEVENTH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AT NINE AM. THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
THREE THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE
WE WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY AT
NINE AM.